I'd say I love you all dude it's so
inspiring
my heartfelt thanks to the Academy
governor's never in my wildest dreams
did I imagine that I would be standing
here and so many individuals contributed
to my fulfilling career
Robert was was responsible for my start
in motion pictures which then gave me an
opportunity to collaborate with many of
the most gifted directors in film
history
they were always open to a new talent
they they've never encountered and
incidentally opened is one of my
favorite word's because as I've said
many times you never know where or when
you will find the answer and I found the
answer in some very strange places my
search for the ideal choice led me to
nearly every state in the United States
all around America and in 1961 John
Sturges sent me to Europe to cast The
Great Escape and then it allowed me to
explore actors in so many remarkable
locations and and bring an authenticity
german's playing Germans Brits and the
rest of the cast it was just
an amazing experience and my career has
never been boring or locking in
surprises Norman Jewison 0 tonight
I love so many people and he's certainly
on that list we had a lot of fun
together
it was really you know not just serious
work but joy but there must be some
major attention to detail to never
compromise is the key no matter what the
size of the role even even if it's a
reaction to something that other actors
is bringing and it allowed me to reach
out a helping hand and find
opportunities for actors and actresses
from the theater the theater
just embarking of their careers
sometimes just a line or few and
sometimes with a roll that became a
stepping stone to great acclaim boy said
warlord and I treasured the ongoing
relationships I've had of so many actors
Jeff Bridges Bruce Dern Andy Garcia
Martin Landau John Travolta Christopher
Reeve his talent so many gifted
individuals I've touched my life and I
want to express my special appreciation
to my associates and my assistants
through the years it would have been
impossible for me to be able to
concentrate and give a hundred percent
to each director without their tireless
contribution casting is alive and well
in the new millennium I so admire the
achievements of today's casting
directors and I'm so impressed with
their creative their creative
contributions and of course the frosting
on the cake tonight is having my loving
family here with me my son and daughter
my grandchildren Nicholas and Kayla
Bella
and my dear friends to share this
incredible honor momentous occasion I
love you thank you